[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat et de reportage sur
Public Sénat vous le savez la promesse
est dans le titre donner du sens à
l'actualité vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des crises que nous
traversons et justement c'est avec la
nouvelle démonstration de force
militaire de la Chine que nous ouvrons
cette émission des manœuvres pour
encercler Taiwan comment expliquer ce
regain de tension la Chine pourrait-elle
vraiment envahir cette île voisine
démocratique et arrimée à la puissance
américaine quelles conséquence aussi de
l'interview d'Emmanuel Macron sur une
Europe qui je cite ne doit pas se
laisser entraîner dans des crises qui ne
sont pas les siennes réponses dans une
minute et puis pour notre second débat
c'est un gros plan sur l'avenir de nos
centrales nucléaires que je vous propose
est-il fragilisé à court et moyen terme
par le réchauffement climatique c'est la
question posée par cette magistrate de
la Cour des comptes
des conséquences du changement
climatique vont infecter et affectent
déjà à des degrés divers mais croissants
les réacteurs du parc national actuel
mais je le dis un peu sur la nainement
les faftera encore plus les projets de
construction des nouveaux réacteurs
susceptibles d'entrer en service à
partir de 2035
sécheresse et pénurie d'eau
mettent-elles nos centrales en tension
en danger dès cet été et puis les futurs
EPS sont-ils adaptés comment les adapter
à la nouvelle donne climatique ne ratez
pas la confrontation des arguments de
nos experts ce sera dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord donc retour sur ce
week-end de tension autour de l'île de
Taïwan avec Mathias Arès
la Chine se prépare à boucler Taiwan
pendant trois jours Pékin a multiplié
les opérations dans le détroit qui
sépare le continent de l'île déploiement
de navires de guerre exercice de blocus
aériens l'armée chinoise a répondu avec
fermeté à la tournée américaine de la
président taïwanaise
en tant que Présidente je représente mon
pays dans le monde entier la Chine
utilise cette excuse pour lancer des
exercices militaires créant de
l'instabilité à Taïwan et dans la région
ce n'est pas l'attitude responsable d'un
grand pays
un exercice de force qui pourrait en
appeler d'autres d'après les autorités
chinoises si Taïwan persiste dans sa
volonté d'indépendance la Chine prendra
de manière résolue des mesures fortes
pour protéger la souveraineté nationale
et l'intégrité territoriale Taiwan est
une partie inséparable du territoire
chinois il n'existe pas de soi-disant
ministère Taïwan et de la défense des
manœuvres qui inquiète jusqu'aux
États-Unis ce lundi la marine américaine
a mené une opération avec un destroyer
en mer de Chine méridionale une
intrusion immédiatement dénoncée par
Pékin
et pour en débattre j'accueille Sylvie
Berman bonsoir bienvenue ancienne
ambassadrice de France notamment en
Chine entre 2011 et 2014 et puis vous
publiez ce livre madame l'ambassadeur
aux éditions talandiers Emmanuel Véron
bonsoir bienvenue spécialisé de la Chine
contemporaine associée à l'INALCO et à
l'École navale Elvire Fabry bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
chercheur à l'Institut Jacques Delors et
rapporteur de l'étude construire
l'autonomie stratégique de l'Europe face
à la Chine j'accue également émis des
appels ski bonsoir Émilie et
victorialise pour sens public merci
d'être là ce matin encore ce mardi matin
même si Pékin a annoncé la fin des
exercices et restait selon Taïwan des
navires de guerre des avions chinois
autour de Lille Sylvie Berman c'est pas
la première fois évidemment que la Chine
se livre à une telle démonstration de
force il fallait s'y attendre après la
visite de la présidente taïwanaise aux
États-Unis c'est aussi simple que ça ah
oui c'était inévitable ils les ont menés
un exercice en grandeur nature après la
visite de à Taïwan au mois d'août
dernier d'ailleurs les Taïwanais étaient
pas très chauds pour l'accueillir elle
s'est invitée mais ça a fourni ce
prétexte aux Chinois donc il était
évident que cette fois-ci ils allaient
réagir également j'ai lu que c'était
moins important que les premiers
exercices du mois d'août mais enfin un
peu importe de toute façon c'est un côté
stablement une démonstration de de force
pour rappeler que Taiwan est un intérêt
vital de la Chine et il réagiront à
chaque fois qu'il considéreront que il y
a une provocation ou de Taïwan ou de ou
des États-Unis ceux qui le considèrent
les Chinois comme une provocation
évidemment considère comme une
provocation pour les Européens c'est
différent parce que nous on est sur une
ligne de maintien du statu quo et et
protection de la fin respect de la
liberté de navigation dans le détroit ça
veut dire que ces exercices auxquels on
a assisté pendant le week-end ils
étaient préparés depuis longtemps
évidemment on déploie pas de telle force
comme ça du jour au lendemain oui
c'était prévu c'était anticipé tout ça
fait l'objet d'une concertation intera
puisque précisément ces manœuvres sur
trois jours et c'est important je crois
de le rappeler côté chinois sont intermé
c'est-à-dire on fait évoluer de plus en
plus entre guillemets dans la profondeur
stratégique à la fois des éléments de la
marine chinoise mais aussi des éléments
aériens et aussi des éléments aéro
terrestres et tout ça devrait être
combiné si vous voulez pour mettre une
pression continue très forte très haute
sur Taïwan pour un terme simuler des
exemples de blocus simuler un
étranglement Taïwan ça permet aux forces
chinoises d'interagir davantage entre
elles également et on le rappellera
peut-être d'avoir emporté sur les jet
fighter sur les avions de chat sur les
bombardés stratégies etc de l'équipement
et des armes pour de vrai c'est pour ça
qu'on parlait de mal réel c'est plus des
missiles de l'équipement réel etc et
effectivement létal comme on l'entend
parfois sur ces exercices là sur ces
manœuvres là mais c'était le cas
précédemment où on est c'est toujours un
peu un peu le même schéma c'est très
codifié en matière militaire dans la
figure la codification le protocole si
je puis dire une adaptation par rapport
au contexte diplomatique qui n'est
effectivement pas tout à fait le même de
la visite de Nancy Pelosi en août 2022 à
Taïwan où on avait davantage d'aéronefs
davantage de bateaux et des exercices
entre guillemets qui ont duré plus
longtemps là on est sur une visite en
transit de pardon de saiwan sur le
territoire américain et donc une
adaptation si je puis dire du process
industriel du process militaire chinois
dans le détroit et autour de Taïwan et
lui fabrique alors vu d'ici et de mon
regard de béotien c'était peut-être la
même chose les j'ai pas vérifié
d'ailleurs vous allez me le dire est-ce
que ce simulacre d'encerclement c'était
déjà le cas précédemment ou alors est-ce
qu'il y a un symbole supplémentaire que
les Chinois veulent
démontrer ou veut l'apporter ce weekend
là ce que certains c'est que ça offre
une formidable occasion d'entraînement
de d'opéra de nouvelles opérations
grandeur nature et en effet
l'encerclement on anticipe deux de
scénario principaux qui sont soit une
invasion en bonne année due forme de
Taïwan soit une logique de blocus qui
serait plus un blocus économique qui est
qui permettrait de limiter les
approvisionnements de Taïwan et qui
finalement affaibliraient
progressivement la résistance
potentielle de toute façon serait bien
réelle de Taïwan donc oui c'est une
logique où il renforce
le isafine si je puis dire un peu leur
stratégie mais ce que l'on voit là c'est
qu'on n'est pas dans une logique de
surenchère en effet on compte le nombre
d'avions on se demande
après c'est la fois précédente mais
c'est pas une logique de surenchère
autant il y a aucune surprise et on
s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait un exercice
militaire on tend autant en voix que si
j'ai ping se saisit de location marque
un point et qu'on est et que bien
entendu en face il s'agit pas non plus
de jouer la surenchère sur cet épisode
et alors c'est sans doute aussi l'un des
objectifs de la Chine c'est que nous
médias occidentaux on vous pose cette
question est-ce que une invasion de la
Chine est possible enfin je voilà je
suis pas dupe de la volonté chinoise
mais on doit se la poser cette question
suivie Berman entre des exercices comme
cela et une invasion il y a un pas un
très grand pas que la Chine est prête
pas prête à franchir qu'est-ce que vous
répondez je crois que là ça relève de
l'avertissement et de la dissuasion là
aussi d'après les militaires les chinois
ne sont absolument pas en mesure
d'occuper Taïwan pour le moment parce
que bon ils ont aujourd'hui une force
maritime c'est vous le spécialiste mais
qui n'est pas complètement au niveau non
plus il y a la question de
l'interopérabilité d'ailleurs c'était
l'intérêt de cet exercice c'est
un des trois de 140 km de large ce n'est
pas facile et en fait
l'armée chinoise n'a jamais encore été
engagé dans des opérations bon l'armée
terrestre ça remonte à 1919 79 contre le
Vietnam et ça a été un échec donc je
pense que il y a encore beaucoup de
choses à faire maintenant il y a aussi
l'opportunité politique donc s'il
conseille est considère qu'il y a un
risque ils seront peut-être tentés
d'intervenir mais je pense pas qu'il
qu'il soit prêt ni militairement ni
politiquement d'ailleurs et le faire
dans les médias on a l'impression que
c'est aussi un moyen de montrer ses
muscles forcément vous l'avez dit il
prépare il montre qu'ils sont capables
et qui monte en puissance sur tout la
tiraille qui est proposé c'est un petit
peu le retour ou en tout cas le vent en
poule de ces régimes autoritaires qui
nous refont par les militaires
finalement puisqu'on a la même chose en
miroir avec la Russie et l'Ukraine de
dire ben voilà moi je suis autoritaire
vous avez fait ce que vous vouliez en
gros aux Etats-Unis l'Irak tout ce qui
s'est passé et maintenant avec cette
puissance qu'on a militaire ou pas
puisqu'on a vu qu'en Russie c'était
quand même limité en termes de puissance
mais qui a ce retour du militaire et on
voit bien qu'en face pour les
démocraties c'est très compliqué de
répondre parce que comme vous l'avez dit
on va pas faire de l'escalade on va
juste contrer et prévenir de cette
menace mais on peut pas aller en avant
on voit bien qu'en Ukraine on a du mal à
avancer plus et on voit que c'est un
petit peu un statu quo sur la guerre
donc c'est un nouvel état du monde quand
même et reparler du militaire à ce point
puisqu'il y a des gares quand même qui
se passent dans le monde mais à ce point
avec des blocs qui se reconstituent
c'est assez impressionnant on a
l'impression qu'on passe à une autre
époque dans ce siècle avec des budgets
militaires on en a parlé récemment
notamment à propos de la France qui sont
plus les mêmes et Emmanuel verrons on
fait le parallèle avec avec la Russie et
l'Ukraine ont peut-être voilà ça a été
une erreur collective ou quasi
collective on avait peut-être un peu
surestimé la puissance de l'armée russe
est-ce que on connaît bien bien l'état
de la puissance de l'armée chinoise vous
voyez ce que je veux dire probablement
pour un tas de raisons qu'on ne connaît
pas suffisamment en profondeur pour les
raisons qui sont celles de
l'accessibilité à la Chine précisément
et on ne connaît pas assez en profondeur
les capacités chinoises ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'effectivement on a un saut
capacités sur toutes les armées y
compris dans le spatial dans le cyber
etc mais aussi un saut qualitatif
c'est-à-dire on a plus de bateaux plus
d'avions etc mais des programmes
d'armement modernes avec des armes entre
guillemets disruptives en tout cas des
armes très modernes etc mais le sujet
essentiel pour nous et pour les sujets
taiwanais c'est fondamentalement
l'inexpérience de la guerre moderne
c'est-à-dire que les troupes chinoises
s'entraînent tout le temps font beaucoup
de manœuvres très démonstrative
démonstration de force quasiment tous
les jours quand on regarde les canaux
chinois etc que ça soit un grand Ouest
chinois avec les Russes avec les
Iraniens sur mer sur terre etc mais ils
n'ont pas l'expérience propre de la
guerre moderne de la haute intensité et
de toutes les complications de la guerre
réelle sous le feu et donc on ne sait
pas comment réagirait les soldats
chinois sous le feu leur comportement
les chaînes de commandement les de
logistique et la combinaison entre les
différentes armes qu'elles soient
aériennes terrestres ou navale dans les
deux hypothèses dont on parlait elle
vient fabriquer tout à l'heure celle du
blocus vous semble plus a priori oui
logique entre guillemets que celle du
invasion et ce qui correspondrait si je
puis dire à une forme de continuité de
la culture stratégique chinoise
c'est-à-dire que je brandi la
possibilité de la guerre de l'usage
martial de l'usage militaire mais je
vais préférer au dernier moment ne pas
tirer un coup de feu pourquoi parce que
je brandi la menace militaire pour
tester les réactions en face et la
précisément pendant trois jours
d'exercice qui se poursuivent d'ailleurs
tous les deux jours cette semaine tester
les réactions taïwanaises tester les
réactions régionales au niveau du Japon
voir le comportement diplomatique ou
militaire de l'Asie du Sud-Est et bien
évidemment derrière des États-Unis et
par extension éventuellement l'Europe et
surtout ce que je vais privilégier c'est
éviter de tirer un coup de feu des
stratégies indirectes à l'usive ou
implicites et en ce sens le blocus la
perturbation des chaînes du transport
maritime l'assèchement voire d'une
influence sur la société taïwanaise
elle-même de découragement sera
privilégié alors vous gagnez
d'intervenir allez-y justement sur ce
point c'est qu'il est probable qu'ils
anticipe qu'une invasion militaire
susciterait une réaction défensive
beaucoup plus cohésive les Taïwanais
alors qu'une logique de de blocus
économique qui serait plus graduelle
progressif pourrait permettre aussi
d'acquérir à un moment donné quelques
éléments de la population qui préférait
limiter l'impact plutôt que d'avoir les
leçons de la guerre ukrainienne enfin de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine pardon d'autant
plus que il y a tout l'engagement
militaire mais il y a aussi tout ce que
si Jean Ping est en train de préparer
sur le volet économique en essayant de
désolariser ces échanges commerciaux
pour anticiper aussi ce que pourrait
être l'application de sanctions venant
des des soutiens de tous les pays alliés
de Taïwan alors je vous propose une
première réaction dans notre débat côté
chinois celle du porte-parole du
ministère chinois des Affaires
étrangères c'était au troisième jour de
ces exercices militaires on l'écoute
la question de Taïwan est une affaire
purement internale à la Chine le
principe d'une seule Chine fait l'objet
d'un large consensus au sein de la
communauté internationale est
constituent une norme fondamentale des
relations internationales actuellement
la plus grande menace pour la paix dans
le détroit de Taïwan et le séparatisme
indépendantiste taïwanais sa connivence
avec les forces étrangères et le soutien
de ces dernières une seule signe Sylvie
berbin c'est le principe qui est brandi
pourtant je pense ne pas me tromper
Taïwan n'a jamais appartenu à la
République populaire de Chine
n'était appartenait à la Chine depuis le
17e siècle des
occupations mais bon le
fait en fait marquant c'est quand Jean
cachec est allé se réfugier dans l'île
en portant le trésor chinois et voulant
reconquérir et c'est à partir de ce
moment-là d'ailleurs qui a eu cette
notion d'une seule Chine pour le coming
Tang à Taïwan la Chine CPE ils allaient
reconquérir le continent et puis bon
ensuite effectivement à Pékin bon est
considéré que Taïwan est parti
intégrante de la Chine mais cela étant
quand il y a eu
reconnaissance de la Chine de la
République populaire de Chine et
établissement de relation diplomatiques
les pays ont dû accepter la politique
d'une seule Chine ce qui est
embarrassant peut-être aujourd'hui et ce
qui crée effectivement une ambiguïté
stratégique et ce qui explique aussi les
tensions diplomatiques dont on va
reparler tout de suite avec Quentin
calmé qui doit être juste là bonsoir
Quentin puisque on s'en rend compte à
les déplacements de personnalités
politiques à Taïwan ça te manque pas on
le ça provoque toujours des réactions
des polémiques que ce soit des
parlementaires américains ou français ou
européens voilà on l'a vu par exemple en
août dernier avec la visite de Nancy
Pelosi à l'époque présidente de la
Chandeleur représentants les États-Unis
devront payer le prix de leur atteinte à
la souveraineté à la sécurité de la
Chine avait dit alors un porte-parole de
la diplomatie chinoise sans suivront et
bien les plus importantes manœuvres
militaires de la Chine autour de Taïwan
à l'époque du jour plus tard rebelote
Thomas une délégation de parlementaire
américain il retourne en réponse
justement à ces manœuvres militaires
alors que la Chine continue à faire
monter les tensions dans la région le
Congrès américain a de nouveau envoyé
une délégation de haut niveau à Taïwan
démontrant ainsi une amitié qui n'est
pas effrayée par les menaces de la Chine
et soulign le soutien résolu les
Etats-Unis envers Taïwan avait dit le
ministre taïwanais des Affaires
étrangères enfin le 7 septembre c'est
une délégation française qui était
accueillie par les autorités locales en
l'occurrence vous voyez sur ces images
Remus lit Kyo chaîne le directeur
général des affaires européennes
ministère des Affaires étrangères total
la délégation était composé de 5
sénateurs Olivier Cadix Cyril pelva
Brigitte devezat Pierre-Antoine Levy
Alain Marc ce sont des élus centrist qui
sont les indépendants ou encore
rattachés au groupe LR là on voyait
alors arrivé à l'aéroport ils étaient
filmés en direct par les chaînes locales
dans un communiqué c'est sénateur
écrivent alors la France rappelle sa
volonté de préserver le statut quo dans
le détroit de Taïwan les sénateurs
rappellent la formule lancée il y a un
an Taïwan n'est pas seul écoutez en
l'occurrence le sénateur qui avait
publié ce communiqué c'est Olivier Cadix
sur notre plateau quelques jours après
sa visite l'idée quand le message a été
lancé l'année dernière
Taïwan n'est pas seul c'était pour bien
montrer que cette île avec ses 24
millions d'habitants face à ce continent
en face qui réclamait qui considère que
Taïwan fait partie intégrante de la
Chine ce peuple qui vit dans une
démocratie qui a choisi ces dirigeants
qui choisissent son destin qui réussit à
se développer est un modèle démocratique
et il fallait bien rappeler à Taïwan que
ce modèle là c'est le modèle que nous
partageons voilà on l'entend une manière
d'exprimer le soutien des sénateurs à
l'exécutif local attaquer Taïwan s'est
attaqué toutes les démocraties avaient
écrit le sénateur Olivier Cadic qu'on
vient de voir merci beaucoup Quentin
agir Fabrice est-ce que la réaction elle
est forte bon là on parle des sénateurs
français mais c'est une autre dimension
et une autre puissance de réaction
diplomatique quand ça concerne
évidemment
les parlementaires américains ou un
officier américain quel qu'il soit ou
comme on vient de le voir une visite
taïwanaise aux États-Unis enfin c'est
aussi un bras de fer six mois américain
que les choses soient claires on est au
coeur du bras de fer si des Chinois
américains et là c'est pas seulement
Chine Occident vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est encore plus puissant quand
c'est uniquement les États-Unis oui
parce que ce sont les États-Unis qui
sont la garantie de sécurité de Taïwan
et quand Taïwan soutient à la fois
l'effort de production de semis
conducteur sur le territoire américain
en même temps il s'inquiète aussi que
cette dépendance qu'on les Américains au
semi-conducteur taïwanais puissent en se
réduisant réduire éroder aussi un petit
peu le le soutien en matière de sécurité
à Taïwan si ce n'est que les États-Unis
en s'engageant à soutenir Taïwan ont
tous sont aussi regardés par toute une
série de partenaires dans la région la
Corée du Sud le Japon l'Australie et que
là c'était aussi un message global qui
est envoyé à l'adresse de tous ses
partenaires à la fois économiques et
des sécurités
a besoin évidemment de américaine
sylverman mais est-ce que elle est pas
aussi un peu l'otage du bras de fer
entre les États-Unis et la Chine si tout
à fait d'ailleurs ce qui nous revient de
certains taïwanais c'est que certains
sont inquiets de cette situation
je me souviens qu'à l'époque où j'étais
à Londres c'était avant l'élection de
Donald Trump l'équipe de
Hillary Clinton était venu à Londres
avait demandé à rencontrer les Français
les Anglais les Allemands justement sur
le thème de la politique vis-à-vis de la
Chine et les Américains avaient demandé
à ce moment-là est-ce que vous pensez
vous européen que nous américains on en
fait trop et qu'on met de l'huile sur le
feu donc je trouve que la question était
intéressante venant des des Américains
eux-mêmes mais effectivement le risque
c'est un peu la prophétie
auto-réalisatrice et le fait de dire on
va vous soutenir on va se battre pour
vous on va vous défendre risque
effectivement de générer davantage de
tension donc il y a effectivement
cette inquiétude à Taïwan bon en même
temps ils ont besoin bien évidemment du
soutien des des Nations Unies et qui
sont garanties par les textes qui ont
été adoptés parce que comme les
États-Unis ont reconnu la Chine plus
tardivement que les autres pays ils ont
maintenu un certain nombre de relations
avec Taiwan y compris d'ailleurs la
fourniture d'armes dans enfin dans
certaines limites mais mes Taïwan est
reconnu par la communauté internationale
uniquement c'est pour ça que en fait il
y a beaucoup d'ambiguïté il y a
l'autonomie c'est une démocratie
effectivement on peut avoir des
relations avec
Taïwan à condition que ce soit
effectivement pas au plus haut niveau
mais il y a eu ce qu'on a appelé la
politique du chéquier pour
l'établissement de relation diplomatique
au début la Chine était très pauvre et
donc Taïwan payait plus la situation
s'est inversée aujourd'hui les Chinois
paient davantage donc il reste quelques
pays en Amérique centrale d'où la visite
de timing dans la région avant d'aller
en Californie qu'est-ce que vous voudrez
de la part de responsabilité les
Américains dans le dans les tensions
actuelles autour de autour de Taïwan
mais je crois que comme le disait Sylvie
Berman il y a les questions de la
garantie de sécurité c'est à dire ça
remonte au Taïwan relevation actes 1979
qui comme on le les mots le disent le
précise garantit de sécurité les
Américains se doivent d'intervenir ou
d'agir ou d'être présent en cas d'une
agression d'une invasion et tout ça a
été écrit et concrètement ça se traduit
par quoi de la livraison d'armements
dans une échelle qui est graduée et on
voit que ces transferts se sont
confirmés avec la succession des
différentes administrations depuis la
fin Obama jusqu'aujourd'hui à bayden
avec Trump entre les deux deuxièmement
la formation d'officiers des contacts
étroits entre les états majors échange
de renseignements sur différents sujets
a priori mais aussi la livraison
différents appareils etc pour participer
à l'effort de défense de Taïwan
précisément dans le cas de la One China
policy mais de la stabilité en
Asie-Pacifique ou plus largement en
Indo-Pacifique donc effectivement il y a
cette
ligne de crête qu'on pourrait entendre
parfois mais qui est bien une garantie
de sécurité c'est un sujet fondamental
qui divise en malgré le côté bip artisan
américain à la veille des élections
présidentielles aux États-Unis aussi
bien républicain que démocrate et qui
est un véritable enjeu fondamental en
matière de politique étrangère des
États-Unis pour 2024 alors ces exercices
militaires chinois ils ont été
déclenchés juste après le départ
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était en visite
d'État apk je reviens vers vous si
viverman parce que c'est vraiment une
question pour la diplomate c'est elle
est volontairement naïve mais les
Chinois auraient-ils pu commencer ces
manœuvres alors qu'Emmanuel Macron était
encore sur le territoire sur leur
territoire
était antérieure donc ils ont pu
commencer avant et je crois que peut
effectivement ils ont décidé d'attendre
pour le faire et la visite d'Emmanuel
Macron a été en fait une visite très
enfin très réussie à la fois d'un point
de vue chinois et d'un point de vue
français il y a des égards qui lui ont
été accordés en particulier la rencontre
en tête à tête à Canton et il y a eu
effectivement des vraies discussions
entre eux donc il y avait eu un choix de
bien traité la France qui est souvent
été le cas d'ailleurs mais là il y en
avait un petit peu plus
la Chine a le souci de se concilier les
Européens précisément dans la
perspective de ce bras de fer entre les
États-Unis et elle-même elle avait reçu
scholls fait le chancelier Scholl sans
début d'année Pedro Sanchez également
l'espagnol et donc effectivement il y a
un peu une opération de charme vis de
l'Europe parce qu'elle ne considère pas
que l'Europe est complètement inféodée
aux États-Unis contrairement à la vision
de Vladimir Poutine avec son Occident
collectif alors vous me tournez la
perche pour parler avec vous Emilie de
cette interview donnée par Emmanuel
Macron donc on est on est juste après
son départ de de Chine interview qui
fait beaucoup réagir depuis deux jours
oui puisque donc il revient de Chine il
avait essayé de convaincre le Président
chinois de revenir de ramener la Russie
à la raison sur l'Ukraine sans vraiment
y arriver et il accorde dans l'avion un
entretien à plusieurs médias français un
entretien donc qui a provoqué beaucoup
de réactions je vous explique dans cette
interview Emmanuel Macron exhorte
l'Europe de ne pas être suiviste ni des
États-Unis ni de la Chine sur la
question de Taïwan une sorte de en même
temps diplomatique voici en quelques
mots ce qu'il a déclaré notre priorité
n'est pas de nous adapter à l'agenda des
autres dans toutes les régions du monde
le paradoxe serait qu'au moment où nous
mettons en place les éléments d'une
véritable autonomie stratégique
européenne nous nous mettions à suivre
la politique américaine par une sorte de
réflexe de panique alors si l'idée de
renforcer l'autonomie stratégique de
l'Europe avec la redistribution
géopolitique qui est en cours ça semble
assez pertinent le timing est un peu le
mal choisi avec les manœuvres militaires
chinoises autour de l'île de Taïwan et
le tolé provoqué en témoigne alors
racontez-nous ces réactions il y en a eu
beaucoup alors il y en a beaucoup c'est
beaucoup c'est le c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire déjà du côté des États-Unis
tout d'abord au sein de la presse le
Wall Street Journal il attitré sur les
gafs de Macron sur Taïwan et l'Ukraine
avec une petite accusation du président
français qui serait une sorte de
mauvaise imitation de Charles de Gaulle
les élus américains aussi ont réagi a
été ont été très choqués par ces propos
à l'image du républicain Marc Rubio on
ne peut plus clair dans sa réactions en
vidéo sur Twitter on l'écoute tout de
suite
je pense que c'est le bon moment pour
nous de demander à l'Europe si Macron
parle au nom de toute l'Europe est-ce
que Macron est maintenant à la tête de
l'Europe est-il maintenant le dirigeant
le plus puissant d'Europe parce que s'il
l'est il y a des choses que nous devons
changer premièrement l'Europe est
particulièrement la France dépend
fortement des États-Unis depuis
plusieurs années pour sa propre défense
en fait lorsque Macron a essayé de jouer
le rôle de superpuissance mondiale et
d'envoyer des troupes en Afrique du Nord
pour combattre les terroristes il n'a
même pas pu y envoyer ses propres
troupes nous avons dû les faire voler
là-bas et nous avons dû les faire
revenir il ne pouvait même pas envoyer
ses propres troupes là-bas donc s'ils
suivent l'exemple de Macron cela nous
fera économiser beaucoup d'argent et le
républicain poursuit aussi sur l'aide
évidemment apporter par les États-Unis
dans le cadre de la gare en Ukraine
jusqu'à maintenant ça a permis à assez
l'inscrit aussi de tenir bon face à
Poutine en Europe aussi beaucoup de
réactions il y a eu un collectif des
lieux européen dont des parlementaires
français qui ont pris position dans un
communiqué se disant consterné avec dans
ce communiqué bref
[Musique]
d'abord je suis pas certaine que ce soit
une gaffe ça a eu lieu dans un avion
donc on a le sentiment que c'est sous le
coup de la confidence mais en fait c'est
juste le rappel d'un d'un principe
fondamental de la doctrine d'autonomie
stratégique des manuel Macron et
finalement ce qu'il dit c'est que la
priorité des Européens c'est d'avoir
l'Ukraine on doit canaliser nos
capacités sur l'Ukraine et il
sous-entend qu'on n'aurait pas forcément
les moyens d'intervenir d'être vraiment
un gamechanger d'avoir un rôle dans ce
qui est une aussi une escalade plus
large d'un confrontation vous le disiez
il y a quelques minutes entre les
États-Unis et la Chine et finalement
ce qui regrettable c'est que ça
intervient juste après le l'intervention
coordonnée avec consulat vanderleyen et
Emmanuel Macron et en attendait qu'il y
ait cette position européenne alors que
cela va venir venait de faire un
discours qui clarifie à la position
parce que la Chine ils sont ensemble en
Chine ils ont eu ils ont eu cet
entretien
en Chine avec avec le président sigmping
c'était important qu'il y ait cette
coordination même si on a eu le
sentiment que la coordination elle-même
sur le fond n'était pas forcément oui
alors c'est ce que j'avais vous demander
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a eu
effectivement coordination ou plutôt de
son de cloche différente entre la
présence de la Commission européenne et
le prix en France il y a eu plus que des
nuances c'est à dire que cela va Leon a
rappelé que l'Union européenne n'était
pas dans une logique de découplage donc
d'alignement sur la stratégie américaine
mais plus dans une logique de réduction
des risques et Emmanuel Macron a eu une
tonalité un peu un peu moins offensive
je dirais sur l'évaluation des risques
donc il est plus dans une démarche de
dialogue de et avec l'arrivée aussi avec
des intérêts offensifs économiques
bilatéraux au niveau franco chinois
ce que l'on peut penser c'est que un
sujet qui n'a pas été tellement abordé
ou en tout cas souligner dans les
commentaires médiatiques à travers
l'Europe c'est qu'il y a quand même une
préoccupation sont très spécifiques
aujourd'hui pour les Européens qui
s'engagent dans une accélération de la
transition verte produire de manière
massive des technologies vertes c'est
que là la Chine est déjà en train
d'envoyer des signaux de coercition
économique qui pourrait être très
offensif en limitant les exportations de
minerai stratégique dont on a besoin
pour nos technologies et que la réduire
les risques vis-à-vis de la Chine ça
veut dire essayer de
essayer de mesurer cette aléa et ne pas
être dans une logique non plus de
provocation vis-à-vis de la Chine parce
que ça pénaliserait directement toutes
l'économie européenne et puis Emmanuel
Macron et les Européens ont quand même
quelques raisons d'en vouloir aux
États-Unis en ce moment on a fait il y a
peu de temps à débat sur le live in
fashion réduction actes qui est une
espèce de dément d’aspirateur à projet
de décarbonation notamment pour les
grands groupes européens qui qui cèdent
aux sirènes des dollars américains bon
c'est un joli coup de protectionnisme
mais ça
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'il
tient parce que il y a effectivement la
question de Taiwan et de la défense de
Taïwan mais c'est autre chose la
relation entre les États-Unis et la
Chine c'est un peu une confrontation de
deux super puissants et les États-Unis
ne veulent pas être déplacés dépassés
par la Chine d'où les le blocus
technologique américain contre contre la
Chine et évidemment les Américains vont
demander aux Européens de payer
l'addition sur l'Ukraine en
soutenant leur position et je pense que
c'est ça que Emmanuel Macron ne veut pas
et pas seulement lui je pense qu'il y a
d'autres Européens mais l'Europe est
divisée sur ce point les petits Atlantis
que d'autres quoi ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les pays d'Europe de l'Est qui
avaient constitué ce groupe 17+1 avec la
Chine et qu'il était les plus favorables
en fait à des investissements chinois
une présence chinoise on complétement
retourner leurs veste entre guillemets
et maintenant sont totalement
atlantistes à cause de de l'intervention
en Ukraine mais encore une fois moi j'ai
relu l'interview je n'y vois rien de
très nouveau
sur les réactions
et c'est le contexte mais alors
justement sur le contexte Emmanuel Véran
est-ce qu'il a été piégé finalement
Emmanuel Macron puisque il donne cette
interview je le rappelle il est dans
l'avion et et les et l'exercice d'Emma
enfin voilà entre le moment il donne une
interview et le moment il est diffusé
bon il y a eu relecture je pense de
l'Élysée donc on est d'accord il y a
peut-être d'ailleurs il y a peut-être
d'ailleurs certains passages qui ont été
retirés parce que justement il y a eu
les il y a eu les exercices militaires
entre-temps donc il a pas vraiment été
piégé je fais je vais au bout de ma
logique puisque je trouve la réponse
dans la question mais est-ce qu'il
aurait pu sauveter encore un peu plus
son discours parce que il y a eu ces
exercices probablement son jeu de mot il
y a peut-être eu un petit problème de
décalage horaire ou de jet lac
c'est-à-dire que le président arithme
effréné tu es peut-être un petit peu
fatigué sa langue est allé plus loin que
ce qui pouvait lui-même contenir donc je
crois que ça traduit quoi ça traduit
précisément une interrogation sur
nous-mêmes une interrogation sur
nous-mêmes et sur l'avenir de l'Europe
qu'est-ce que l'Europe aujourd'hui un
marché consolidé avec des capacités
technologiques avérées mais qui ne
réalisent pas encore de champion
européen face aux technologies de
rupture américaine aux technologies de
rupture chinoise je pense à la 5G et
pour au palais nommer des groupes par
éthiques côté chinois ou des équivalents
côté américain on n'a pas de concurrents
on n'a pas de champion européen ni
franciliennement je ne sais quoi et que
c'est interviews là ces éléments de
communication
transmis à la presse sur le chemin du
retour de Pékin renvoie bien une
interrogation sur notre sur notre avenir
et je fais le lien tout de suite avec le
discours prononcé par le président
au Pays-Bas ou point par point il
rappelle des sujets de sursaut pour
s'industrialiser sur ce sur les
technologies sur ce sur une
consolidation industrielle à différents
niveaux et peut-être qu'il y aurait là
un besoin de sursaut diplomatique et
politique menée par Paris mais avec une
langue plus peut-être contenue sur
l'Ukraine précisément et à ce stade-là
on serait entendu par la fois nos alliés
américains qui restent nos alliés nos
partenaires en Asie et pour finir par la
Chine on voit que on a un Emmanuel
Macron qui est très volontaire sur le
sujet européen peut-être qu'à la langue
un peu trop enfin voilà de temps en
temps voilà peut-être softisé je sais
pas quoi vous avez dit je m'étais déjà
pas joli donc on peut l'oublier
sa parole mais moi je me pose la
question est-ce que c'est la méthode
Coué c'est du déclaratif pour y arriver
parce que comme vous le dites on entend
souvent cette question industrielle
technologique dans la voie d'Emmanuel
Macron avec cette envie que ça se passe
vraiment où est-ce que ça peut
influencer au fur et à mesure ses
partenaires européens qui en effet ne
sont pas toujours sur la même longueur
d'onde pour au fur et à mesure
convaincre que c'est que cette Europe
elle renaisse et elle pèse à la fois
économiquement sur le plan géopolitique
comme une puissance d'avant qui pourrait
renaître ça je veux bien vous entendre
là-dessus et le vire fabrique est-ce que
c'est du finalement la méthode Coué ou
est-ce que il finit il réussit quand
même petit à petit à convaincre des
partenaires européens de
l'importance de cette troisième voie là
le message s'adresse est clairement
au 26 les autres et d'une certaine façon
il était déjà quasiment dans la viande
retour ce qui était pas le cas mais
c'était un peu c'était un peu la
tonalité que ça donnait il se passe déjà
beaucoup de choses je vous évoquez l'IRA
tout à l'heure dans les réponses
européennes qui sont mises sur la date
sur la table il y a eu une accélération
des initiatives prises par la Commission
européenne maintenant on voit bien qu'il
a voulu donner un sentiment d'urgence
aussi il s'agit pas de se reposer et de
reprendre des des nos divisions
classiques il s'agit d'accélérer la
cohésion des Européens et finalement
c'est le message qui vient de faire
passer dans son discours à la Haley en
disant il faut déjà regarder
au-delà ce dont on a besoin les enjeux
de financement et on sait qu'on va
reparler dans l'enjeu d'une capacité
d'endettement commune et que là on est
déjà en train de passer de des efforts
d'industrialisation dans le secteur des
technologies vertes vers les enjeux
d'armement au moins dans moins dans le
secteur des munitions mais on commence à
rentrer dans le Dieu et on sait que
c'est un domaine dans lequel on avait
beaucoup de mal à avancer
en européen donc c'est pour maintenir
d'une certaine façon un petit peu cette
dynamique avec un petit peu des formules
des formules chocs on se souvient de la
mort cérébrale de l'OTAN et qui avait eu
autant d'écho côté américain et je
dirais d'une certaine façon la réponse
de Marco Rubio qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure et presque enfin et très
contre-productive je dirais pour pour
Washington parce que c'est justement ce
à quoi prépare Emmanuel Macron en disant
ben voilà il faut peut-être se préparer
aussi à ce que cette soutien
indéfectible à l'Ukraine et plus
largement aux Européens puissent aussi
fragiliser en fonction d'alternance
politique de voilà d'évolution de
soutien des opinions publiques ou pas
alors il nous reste quelques minutes et
je voudrais qu'on parle on a commencé à
l'évoquer mais de la réaction américaine
à cet exercice militaire chinois autour
de Taïwan cette encerclement en quelque
sorte simuler l'exercice inter-armée
vous nous l'avez
rappelé je vous propose d'entendre pour
ouvrir ce chapitre le porte-parole du
Département d'État américain avait un
Patel
nous partageons avec d'autres pays un
intérêt constant pour la paix et la
stabilité de part et d'autre du détroit
de Taïwan mais aussi plus largement dans
la région Indo-Pacifique nous continuons
d'exhorter Pékin à cesser ses pressions
militaires diplomatiques et économique
envers Taïwan et de choisir plutôt
d'exercer une diplomatie constructive
alors on est évidemment dans de la voilà
de l'hypothétique et heureusement
Emmanuel Véron que ferait les Américains
s'il y avait resté sur votre hypothèse
d'un blocus chinois effectif autour de
Taïwan c'est une question tout à fait
importante sensible et qui a priori avec
l'agenda qui se précise ces derniers
jours sera probablement visible dans les
prochains mois ou les prochaines années
au regard des échéances électorales à
Taïwan mais aussi américaine le Parti
communiste chinois regarde ça de près
instrumentalise le temps pensez que ça
arrivera très très prochainement où ça
me semble être très plausible et alors
2024 2025 jusqu'à 2027 ça me semble être
très plausible alors intéresserons les
réactions américaines les garanties de
sécurité indépendamment du prochain
locataire ou le même de la Maison
Blanche a priori ne devrait pas bouger
il y aura donc une nécessité de la part
de l'administration américaine d'agir ou
de réagir et donc je pense qu'on va
assister à des formes de dissuasion non
pas nucléaire mais de dissuasion par une
présence militaire qui a engagerait les
Chinois à ne pas franchir une ligne
rouge supplémentaire qui d'ailleurs
ligne rouge est déjà franchie quasi
quotidiennement avec le franchissement
de la zone d'identification défense
aérienne à la fois
identification aérienne mais aussi sur
le diplomate sur la dimension sur la
dimension navale donc les Américains
prépositionnés dans la zone avec
l'architecture de sécurité Japon Corée
du Sud Taïwan et le renforcement des
bases militaires aux Philippines montre
bien montre bien si vous voulez les
dispositifs militaires aux stratégiques
américains précisément sur Taïwan qui
est devenu le centre de gravité des
questions de la rivalité sinon
américaine ce qui est un argument à
rebours de Pékin pour dire regardez les
ingérences etc etc en tout cas les
Américains regardent ça de très très
près il y a un rapprochement des états
majors de l'ensemble des pays alliés des
États-Unis dans la région pour préparer
ce type de scénario d'ailleurs Sylvie
verman il y a depuis aujourd'hui des des
manoeuvres là aussi militaires entre
l'armée américaine et l'armée philippine
donc ça aussi prévu de longue date etc
enfin on est on est dans c'est quoi
c'est de la communication
militaire au diplomatique comment vous
appelez ça c'est ça relève de la de la
dissuasion en disant aux Américains si
en disant au chinois si vous attaquez
Taïwan on est là on a nos bases on a nos
alliés maintenant la question qui se
poserait c'est qu'est-ce qu'il ferait
c'est il fournirait des armes c'est très
clair les Américains vont pas mourir
pour Taïwan non plus donc
là aussi c'est le modèle de c'est le
modèle de ce qui se passe depuis un peu
plus d'un an sur notre soldat le seul
européen la question est ouverte bien
évidemment ça dépendra du nouveau
locataire effectivement de la Maison
Blanche
Trump avait dit un moment assez généraux
en leur montrant le globe terrestre en
disant vous voyez Taïwan vous voyez la
Chine vous voyez où on est donc on n'ira
pas donc évidemment Joe Biden a dit on
défendra Taïwan mais il a pas dit
comment il devrait Taïwan et avec on va
terminer là-dessus elle vient fabriquer
des conséquences économiques il y aurait
un blocus ou un conflit autour de Taïwan
il faut peut-être rappeler que ce
détroit de Taïwan c'est une sorte de
d'autoroute maritime du commerce mondial
c'est c'est majeur quoi exactement il y
a plus de la moitié du commerce mondial
qui passe en fait par là
donc c'est au-delà de la question des
semi-conducteurs que le Taïwan a
provient la façon dont Taïwan
approvisionne le monde entier là c'est
toutes les toutes les chaînes
d'approvisionnement maritimes qui
pourraient connaître des perturbations
importantes et c'est pour ça que c'est
vraiment ces véritable un enjeu qui est
plus que régional et qui concerne
l'ensemble de l'économie mondiale on se
souvient des problèmes de rupture
d'approvisionnement qu'on a eu pendant
la pandémie ça aurait une ça pourrait
prendre une proportion beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus importante et puis encore
une fois je pense qu'il y a 7 ans de
restriction des exportations sur des
biens ciblés qui peuvent venir déjà
perturber très fortement des des chaînes
de d'approvisionnement technologique
pour envoyer des signaux et qui vont et
qui peuvent monter en escalade merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce à ce débat je rappelle Sylvie
Berman le titre de votre livre madame
l'ambassadeur qui est publié aux
éditions taland